caffeine causes headaches caffeine is a
double-edged sword the best way to cure
a hangover is
hangover food the best cure for hangover
is time oh boy migraines can be cured
migraines cannot be cured and i am sorry
to deliver this news today i'm dr deena
kuruvila i'm a neurologist and a
headache specialist with the westport
headache institute in westport
connecticut hi i'm dr cynthia armand i'm
a neurologist and headache specialist at
the albert einstein college of medicine
and headache fellowship director at the
montefiore headache center and today
we'll be debunking myths about headaches
and migraine
migraines are just headaches that is
just the most aggravating myth that i've
ever seen and i'm sure many of my
patients will say the same thing i 100
agree
a headache is a very nonspecific term
for having discomfort or pain in the
head migraine is a neurological disorder
that's not only headaches but is
associated with nausea with vomiting
with sensitivity to light with
sensitivity to sound and so many other
symptoms it's a disease just like asthma
just like diabetes so within migraine
disease there are migraine attacks and
an individual can have
many or very little of them it's very
important to know the difference between
headache and migraine because the
treatments are different a nap will cure
your headache there really isn't
evidence to show that a nap is helpful
for managing a headache or migraine many
of my patients tell me that they take
medication and then they go take a nap
and by the time that they wake up the
headache or the migraine attack is gone
that creates a false sense of treatment
i've certainly found that sleeping too
much or sleeping too little
is a big trigger for patients with
migraine so i always counsel patients
keep your sleep times your wake times
the same every day so that you don't end
up triggering a migraine instead of
napping and this depends on the person
you can start with medication that your
doctor had prescribed to do some
mindfulness and meditation and making
sure that you keep your schedule
consistent caffeine causes headaches
caffeine is a double-edged sword yes
caffeine can be a trigger to headaches
but
caffeine can also be helpful for
headaches have fun drink your latte but
it's really important to recognize
increasing the amount of caffeine you
take in can trigger more headache
attacks or migraine attacks and also
right after the period that you increase
and you decide ah i'm gonna try and cut
it down suddenly
that abrupt withdrawal can also trigger
a migraine attack or a headache now
caffeine can also be useful in treating
headaches or migraine attacks as well
like excedrin that can have caffeine in
it which is excedrin migraine just
remember you're adding that caffeine
from excedrin migraine to the caffeine
you're already taking that could
certainly produce a worsening of
headaches just something to be cautious
about dehydration is the most common
cause of headaches that is definitely
not true dehydration is not the most
common cause for headaches in general
the part that annoys me about this is is
cause what you just talked about are
triggers right so triggers are certain
circumstances or situations that lower
one's threshold to have a migraine
attack in someone who's already
susceptible well dehydration is a common
trigger for folks there are so many
different triggers that have been
reported by patients the most common
ones i hear about are alcohol too much
caffeine or suddenly stopping caffeine
not getting enough sleep and stress it's
really important to keep a headache
diary or a migraine diary because that
allows you to know more about your body
and that allows you to put tabs on
triggers and when attacks happen and
that helps you decide with your doctor
what really is triggering you because
what triggers one person may not trigger
someone else oh boy
migraines can be cured migraines cannot
be cured and i am sorry to deliver this
news today essentially
migraine disease is managed migraine
management consists of preventive
treatments which may be a daily
medication a monthly injectable or a
procedure or treatment with a device
which is a very popular
non-pharmacological option now we always
recommend as needed treatments to limit
your disability with each individual
attack and then we also talk about
non-medication options we talk about
meditation mindfulness acupuncture
vitamins there are so many options
available now that you can seek help to
really get your life back the best way
to cure a hangover is hangover food
there's no cure for hangovers the best
cure for hangover is time the duration
really varies per person i've heard 24
to 72 hours that sounds like a really
long time but everyone's body is
different headaches are usually a
symptom for hangovers because of two
things the first thing is you know
alcohol to be a trigger for migraine
attacks and headache in general the body
actually releases histamine with alcohol
intake in general and that can certainly
also cause migraine attack and the other
portion is the dehydration of the
alcohol dehydration is a trigger for
migraine attacks and headache you could
aggressively hydrate yourself with water
or you can receive fluids through an iv
you can take acetaminophen or an
anti-nausea medication these are all
options that are out there to use before
a night of drinking but certainly not
proven enough for that purpose
taking advil will always treat headaches
and migraines advil is an as needed
over-the-counter medication which is
meant to be used as needed only less
than two days a week and is not used as
a preventive treatment this is like the
vein of my existence because when i see
patients for the first time they're
always on an over-the-counter
anti-inflammatory medication what we
call nsaids the non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories and these nsaids
like advil treat the inflammation
portion however migraine involves all
sorts of chemicals and they wouldn't so
respond to the over-the-counter
anti-inflammatories if medications such
as advil are used more frequently they
can produce medication overuse headache
the newer term for it is medication
adaptation headache how i explain this
is that your body kind of gets used to
it so you take more of the medication
and you get more headache and it's just
this vicious cycle if you find out that
you're using your as needed medications
like advil too frequently please talk to
your doctor about a preventive option
that will overall cut down on your
headaches you don't have to use so much
as needed medications ooh
all migraines are the same
no not all migraine attacks are the same
migraines come in all different flavors
and we can differentiate them in terms
of how often the migraine occurs like
chronic migraine versus episodic
migraine so chronic means any attack
that occurs 15 or more days and then
episodic means less than 15 and then we
can differentiate them on the symptoms
that individuals have there can be
something called hemiplegic migraine
where individuals have weakness on one
side there can be migraine with and
without aura and what aura is is a
transient neurologic symptom which could
be something that you see in your vision
that comes along it could be numbness on
one side of your body it can be
difficulty talking and then there can be
other specific ones like retinal
migraine that's specific to the eye the
different types of migraine have
different risks and different management
patterns for example people who have
migraine with aura may be at a slightly
higher risk of stroke there may be a
specific treatment that works for that
type of migraine so
for counseling purposes and treatment
purposes we really need to know what
type of migraine you have migraines and
headaches only happen on one side of the
head it's definitely false but we always
like a textbook definition of things if
we look up what migraine is most
commonly you'll find that it says it's
one-sided throbbing headache that has
nausea vomiting but actually
again
every individual with migraine is
different migraine pain can be in the
forehead sides of the head back of the
head the face the nose and the neck
around 80 percent or more of patients
with migraine also have neck pain there
are more
rare headache disorders that only occur
on one side of the head cluster headache
happens on only one side of the head
classically so the location of your pain
doesn't necessarily pinpoint what your
diagnosis is what i really find is it's
a compilation of symptoms which is why i
always talk about the diary having a
headache means something is wrong with
your body oh that's a very interesting
question
having a headache doesn't necessarily
mean there's something wrong with your
body headaches can signal more dangerous
things going on in the brain like a
stroke like a tumor like a tear within
one of the arteries of the head or neck
but there are everyday things that can
cause headache ponytail headaches for
example are very common you're tying
your hair back in that really tight bun
braids braids
swim caps there's ice cream headache
where you eat that ice cream and you
notice that headache that comes on right
away and that's because you're kind of
stimulating the upper part of your
palate with that cold temperature so
important to know the red flags of when
something may signal something more
dangerous if you already have headaches
or migraine disease you might want to
pay attention to if there's a changing
pattern if it's still responsive to the
usual treatments that you take if you
are having
extra symptoms added to the migraine
that you haven't had before those are
indications you need to see your
provider to make sure to do some sort of
workup for any other secondary cause
mental health has nothing to do with
migraines no
i just can't with this one so we have to
set the record straight on this one
migraine is the second leading cause of
disability worldwide and actually 50 of
individuals with migraine do experience
anxiety disorders and what that's called
is comorbid conditions we know
that depression anxiety and other mood
conditions are more likely to happen
with individuals with migraine migraine
affects individuals at home their
ability to take care of their family
their ability to earn a living their
ability to enjoy and engage in social
interaction and a lot of the times that
leads to guilt that leads to a sense of
worthlessness and if you don't treat one
condition it's difficult to treat the
other what we do is we treat both at the
same time many of the brain chemicals
that are released during a migraine
attack like dopamine serotonin
norepinephrine they're the same
chemicals that are also involved in mood
disorders like depression and anxiety so
a lot of these medications that are
first indicated for mood disorders
actually work well in individuals with
migraine there are individuals who
specialize in both migraine and mood
disorders that can help so do you want
to do the honors
sure i'd love to
let's really rip this one up
headaches and migraine disease are quite
complex they're experienced differently
in many different individuals so it's
really important to keep a diary keep
track of your individual triggers and
what really makes your headaches worse
and have that dialogue with your
provider in order to help with proper
management and treatment